So there's still questions you want to ask me.
There are, yes.
Just like last time, go ahead and introduce this off.
The name is Dave.
Oh, yes.
My name is Kenneth Hedberg.
This is the 29th of September of 2011.
Okay.
So last time we pretty much finished up with Caltech.
But one thing I realized I forgot to ask you about.
Was any memories you have of baby Helen from that time, too?
Oh, baby Helen?
Yeah.
Only peripherally because I saw her together with her husband fairly frequently.
Excuse me.
And she, of course, was always present at the open houses that they held occasionally.
These open houses, some of the faculty and so on were invited not very many of the students.
I saw her there.
And I saw her a lot, of course, later on when she and Linus came to Oregon State.
But at the time that I was at Caltech, I saw her with Linus a great deal.
And that's about all.
When did you make the move to OSU and what made you decide to make that move?
When did I come to OSU or what?
Well, I don't know.
Have I mentioned it all the circumstances under which I experienced the opening here at Oregon State?
Oh, no, no.
Oh, well, I had been working at Caltech for many years after my doctorate.
And, well, many, five or six.
And I was actively engaged in research and I was stopped in the hole one day by Carl Neiman,
who was a distinguished organic chemist and whom I knew quite well.
He said, can I receive the letter from a former colleague of mine?
A man I went to graduate school with with Wisconsin, who was now at Oregon State.
And he said, they have an opening there.
And he wondered whether I had anybody who would be interested or we here at Caltech,
if anybody who might be interested.
I just thought I'd mention it to you in passing because I remember you were in Oregon State undergrad.
So, at this time, my wife was pretty unhappy in California and Macedonia because of the air pollution.
Our first son was about to be born and she wanted to raise him in that environment.
I said, yes, I'd better explore this.
And so I wrote them to E.C. Gilbert, who wrote back, indeed, they did have an opening.
And one thing followed another and it turned out that my wife and I were going to drive North to Oregon to visit my parents,
who lived at that time in Astoria.
And I said to Gilbert that I would stop on route and talk with him and members of the faculty and discuss the opening.
Then I got another letter from a guy named Bill Colville, William E. Colville,
who let me know in no uncertain terms that the reason this was a job was because he had managed to get the president of the University of A.L. Strand
to commit to two new faculty hires in chemistry.
And it turns out that at that time, well, let me put it this way, Earl Gilbert and Bill Colville were not on the best of terms.
Gilbert was a department chairman and Colville was a professor who did almost, did no research on sight,
but had some mining claims and other things.
And it was kind of an open, free-handed, back-slopping type, a member of the country club and a new E.L. Strand fairly well.
And he complained that the freshman at Oregon State and incoming students were not being given proper instruction because there weren't enough professional staff involved in this, just graduate teaching assistants and so on.
And he managed to convince Strand that perhaps there should be some positions set up.
And these would people, of course, would be nominally responsible to Colville since he was running the whole program.
And the main purpose of the main task of these people were going to be that they would sort of ride herd on all the teaching assistants.
So they would patrol the laboratories, make sure that the teaching assistants were doing their job.
They would, of course, have some responsibilities themselves, bought in the freshman program.
They would hold recitations and they would be in this way and be responsible for laboratories and then, as I mentioned, patrol the laboratories regularly.
So I immediately sensed that there was something, there was a bit of an adversarial relationship between Gilbert and Colville.
And Gilbert, of course, was interested in hiring somebody who could also increase the research potential of the faculty.
Colville wasn't in the least interested in whether these guys could do any research or not.
He just wanted them as sort of major domos.
And so I learned all of this in more detail when I came and talked with Gilbert and talked with Colville.
And I also had numerous conversations with other members of the faculty, people who have passed on now, Tom Nauros, Wendell Slavell, everybody that was on the faculty that I had known before.
And after concluding all these interviews, we drove on down to my terrace, came back to California.
I had told Gilbert it was still a guy who was officially in charge of the hiring that I would think it over and I'd let him know.
So after I got back to Pasadena, I felt for a long time about this, and decided that the conditions of this job were such that I found it unlikely to be able to get my research program going at Oregon State in a reasonable length of time, so I declined the offer, which was $5,500 for nine months.
No, no, nine months, but spread over 10 months.
Well, my wife was very unhappy about this because she liked Oregon more like Oslo, where she grew up in Norway.
As she put it, there was so water in the rivers of Pinarigan and trees in the forest where she couldn't see that in LA.
We drove across a bridge, one place, and I pointed out that this was the San Gabriel River. She looked down, there was no water, it was just a dry wash.
And we went through the San Gabriel forest on the outskirts, so that there's nothing but sagebrush, that's the source of her comments.
At any rate, she was very unhappy about this. And a few days later, I got a call from Gilbert saying he was very sorry to receive my letter.
He had very much hoped that I would accept the job. And he said he wondered if they were able to increase the starting, so I'll read a little bit what I reconsider.
And I said at this time, the home life was a little frosty because at least it was so disappointed. So I said, okay, I'll do that.
Have I told you any of this at all? No, okay.
So the offer came back and he said we can pay you two or three hundred dollars more per year. That's maybe five percent or six percent increase.
And so I asked Paul what he thought about all this. And he invited me to come up to his home one evening after hours, five o'clock or so.
I can't remember exactly, so I went up to 4,500 per point, whatever the street number is, or yeah, he's Allison, he's out on the Miranda and discussed the job.
I've been very active in research at Caltech, and had a number of published papers, lots of things going, and I expressed to him my fear that I was not going to be able to get my research program going at Oregon State because it involved the construction of apparatus.
You saw that apparatus. I had to build that by hand. There were extremely limited machine shop facilities, nothing in the chemistry department at all.
And I didn't see how I could get that instrument built at Oregon State. So I expressed all this to him and then told him that the actual number of hours that I was expected to be in contact with students
was something like 15 or 16 hours a week, just in the hands-on contact. That's about 30 percent, or a little bit more than that, 35 percent of the total time, not counting preparation or anything.
Anne Pauling, sort of lean back in his chair, we were sitting side by side looking out over the valley and the swimming pool.
He said, well, he said, I don't know. He says 15 hours. He said, when I was at Oregon State, I was teaching 40 hours a week.
That was the year that he was a sophomore and had been asked to handle a course for young women in home economics.
I think at those who were taking chemistry as a requirement, that's where he met his wife A. The Helen. But anyway, that's the story, you know.
So anyhow, he said 40 hours. He said, I don't know. He said, I think that Oregon State will not be a first-class institution for research in my time. And probably not on yours. These are his words.
He said, on the other hand, that's not really important in a bigger sense. He said, if you didn't get your program going, these will be very happy there. Oregon is a wonderful place to live, as you and I know.
He said, I don't know. I think it might be worthwhile giving a chance. I think you could make it go on. You'd be very happy there.
So with that encouragement, I told Gilbert up and said, yes, I would accept the offer. And my wife, of course, was delighted at this because at this time our son had just been born.
And we lived in Pasadena, down below, not far from Caltech. And the smog would roll in the morning, about 11 o'clock. And she'd take the baby in, close all the doors and windows.
Keep them closed till about four in the afternoon when the winds reverse their direction and swept all the smog back out to sea again. And she could open things up.
It was pretty hot, too. So I had a hose in this garden cottage that I put on the root and turned on the water to keep it cool during the time that she was so to speak incarcerated.
Anyway, that fall, I told Gilbert that I wouldn't be able to come in the fall by the fall term, but I could come January 1st.
This was January 1st, was 1956. So this was all in 1955. This conversation went on.
So I had come January, we drove north after Christmas in times of a huge storm that actually led to flooding. This was a fine way for my wife to be introduced to the worst vertical of Alice.
You don't know anything today about how it was then, but we drove up to Eugene, got the junction city, and it turned out that the 99 West was closed because of water and the roads.
But there was a bus going up 99 East to Albany and I, with our car, the baby in the back, and we followed this bus very carefully up sometimes.
The water almost up to the hubcaps of the car got to Albany. And then it turned out that the road from Albany to Corvallas was okay.
It wasn't underwater yet, but the road from Corvallas South on 99 West was underwater. So by that we managed to get to Corvallas, and by three arrangements we had run out of the house of a faculty member that was going to be away for three months.
So we had a place to move into immediately, all furnished, very nice house on Chintimini, over there against the hill and south. Well, you know where it is.
It was very nice. And it turned out that everything was flooded the following day or two in Corvallas. You could hardly get around at all. And then it turned cold later on, snow came and so on.
So that was my introduction to Corvallas. I showed up to work on one of the early days and Gilbert told me, oh, they had a kind of a bonus to give me.
And that was that I was going to be assigned to teach a graduate course and physical chemistry to organically and others.
Well, this sounded like a bonus to him, but for somebody just coming there, I mean this was a lecture thrill or as a week and I had never done this course before. So I had all those lectures to prepare as well as stuff I was expected to do under Bill Coldwell's regime.
So I had a very, very busy time and with a newborn in the house of my wife, you know, trying hard to the customer's self to life in a new place with a new baby in a husband who was up to his ears and work wasn't very easy.
I was pretty discouraged at the end of that term. And as the term drew on, I took care to write down on a piece of paper divided into days and hours of the day for a week each week.
How much time I was actually spending in duties connected with teaching by connected with that man in the in with students one on one preparation, including evening hours and everything else.
And I was averaging that first term, 56 hours a week, only in teaching related duties. And so my fear is about getting my program started on the research side. Well, well born out by that first experience.
And of course, I was expected not only to have a program going, getting my research going, but I had to build this apparatus, which meant that I had to design it, sit down with, I think I showed you just briefly, folders with those drawings in there.
I had a drawing table in my office. And so I spent a lot of time with drawing these things. And then Professor Youngter and Physics had a fine physics shop. And I went across to see him and he agreed, you see my life actually, to allow one of the people in physics.
Physics, I think they had three or four machinists who would be assigned to my job. And he would do everything and he and I would be in one to one contact all the time.
He reserved the right to retake this man off for any projects that physics needed, of course, since he was employed by physics and using the physics facilities.
And that worked out just beautifully. Took a long time to get the apparatus built three or four years, but it was finally done and put together and we managed to make it go.
So Ed Youngter's facilities and his kindness really are responsible for getting me off the ground at Oregon State.
So would describe the apparatus a little bit for me.
Sorry. Describe the apparatus for me.
Oh, well, the apparatus is what is called an electron diffraction unit.
It consists of a, the essential feature of it is an electron gun that will produce a well-colonated beam of electrons at the potential of about 60 kiloboles.
It's a very energetic beam on the scale of the way chemistry operates.
That beam is admitted into a large vacuum chamber.
In my apparatus, the whole thing is mounted vertically, so the beam comes down into this vacuum chamber.
And at the bottom of the beam, let's say, is a detecting beam, which is in my case, photographic film.
In those days, there's a photographic plate, but it's no photographic film.
And this photographic film is eight by ten inches square and is perpendicular to the beam and is moved into position by mechanism that I built into the apparatus.
And the apparatus is designed to study the structures of molecules in the gas phase by diffracting this beam of electrons from them.
So we have a long nozzle that protrudes into the apparatus with a tip that passes that stops just about a millimeter short of where there's very fine high-powered electron beam is coming down.
Now, if in this nozzle, which is a two with a fine tip on it, you admit a gas into the chamber, the gas shoots out the nozzle tip, intersects the electron beam at right angles and produces what is called a diffraction pattern.
This diffraction pattern consists of what happens is, of course, it's recorded on this photographic film at the underneath the nozzle.
And perpendicular to the beam.
So the diffraction pattern is recorded on this in a set of diffuse rings of varying intensity.
And the spacing of these rings and their shapes of the pattern contain all the structural information about the length of the interatomic distances in the molecule.
And so we take these patterns and we analyze them and out of that we can deduce the intimate details of the structures of these molecules in the gas phase.
That is essentially, it's a structure of a single molecule because so far apart, they don't interact with one another as they shoot into the apparatus.
And so that's what I was charged with or what I wanted to build and which I finally got going for all those years.
It's still running and running.
Yeah, and it is running and right now and running beautifully, we just did an experiment last week, beautiful patterns we got for a new molecule or interested in.
It doesn't take long for the experiment as quite interesting. The technique is developed enormously since the days when I first entered the field at Caltech as a graduate student.
And now the experiment that lasts is diffraction pattern. You expose the photographic film to the diffraction pattern for only two or three minutes and you might want to make five different films or ten different films.
So all tools you can do the entire experiment in a day if you push it, everything.
And that's all the data you need for what might be for a graduate student a year and a half of work analyzing it.
So the apparatus mostly sits unused because we can quickly gather all the data we knew.
So I've had a lot of visitors who have come, used the apparatus.
And if I had a technician I could supply all the diffraction data for every group in the world.
This technician did nothing but take diffraction pictures of substances involved.
Now it may be a little more complicated because these are gas phase molecules. We admit them in the chamber as a gas.
But that doesn't mean that they have to be a gas as you look at them. You can put them on the table.
The factors you've got to get them into the gas phase in order to make this experiment work.
Well, we have a set of ovens and heated nozzles so we can heat these things up and get the vapor.
C60 that we have worked on, of course, is very intractable, has no vapor pressure at all to speak of.
So we had to heat this substance in an oven to 800 and some odd degrees Celsius in order to get the tiniest bit of vapor from it.
But that was sufficient to give us the diffraction pattern and we were able to determine the structure of this material which is a carbon-like powder on the table.
So we have all sorts of auxiliary apparatus which allows us to produce gas molecules from lots of different circumstances.
So it works very nicely. I'm very happy with it.
I should add as a post-cryptolist that this technique was very powerful through the 40s and 50s and 60s even in the 70s.
But there are other techniques that have developed in the meantime too and so there are fewer laboratories in the world doing this work.
When I came to Oregon State and got mine going, there were about, there were only two laboratories in the United States.
Did this kind of work? Mine and a laboratory at Michigan.
There were other people who, well there was another apparatus built.
It didn't, it worked for a while but not very long.
And there was one of Texas that was built similar to look.
But it was built in the physics department and the interest there was not the same as the interest that chemists had.
And so it worked for a while and then it stopped.
And later on there were apparatuses in Britain.
There was one at Edinburgh. And later on, and still extant, is one in Reading, England.
There was one in Germany, they were very active in Germany.
And when I first started there was one in Belgium and one in Holland and several in at that time the Soviet Union.
And two or three laboratories in Japan, all of them had apparatus and could do experiments.
All those were gone except the apparatus in Reading.
The apparatus in Germany by the way, the man who was the professor who was in charge of that laboratory retired.
His name was Heinz Oberhummer.
And his apparatus has been transferred to an inorganic chemist who is using it as kind of an exaggerate to his main work which is the preparation and interesting inorganic compounds.
And as a part of that he wants to know what those structures are.
The apparatus in Reading is still extant but the man who was in charge of it before has now retired.
And a woman that was working with him has a permanent position at the university but she's heavily involved with teaching and has very little time to work with it.
There were two important laboratories in Norway, I didn't mention them earlier.
Both of them are now gone as far as apparatus is concerned.
There isn't any further support for it in that in science decisions are always made about where you're going to put a limit to the amount of phones.
And in Norway it's now determined that this particular area of research will not be supported anymore by the university in the sense that they will hire technicians and professorial-ranked people to do this kind of work.
And I fear that will probably be the case here at Oregon State too.
So we don't know.
It's a plain fact is it's not judged by what's going on in the world of chemistry today cutting-edge stuff.
A lot of the things that's going on today is shifted more into larger molecule biological things, synthetic organic chemistry, new materials, things of that sort and not the kind of basic science that I was involved with for all those years.
So anyway I came to Oregon State, got a built and I've been here ever since doing this kind of research. That's what it's all about.
It's been great fun.
So what were the techniques that you used to analyze the detection patterns initially?
Well, yes that's a good question. I don't know how much of the technology I ought to go into.
But essentially you're faced with this photographic film. If you hold it up to the light you see the beautiful pattern of circular rings of varying intensity, very diffuse, easily recognized going out from a central point.
And all the information about the structure of the molecules contained as I said earlier in the spacings and the shapes of these rings.
The question then you're really asking is how do you go from that to determine how molecules put together?
Well, it turns out that these rings are related to the structure of the molecule by some, according to theory, by in a rather simple way.
I'll keep it as simple as I possibly can.
Every interatomic distance in the molecule creates an effect on this film, a pattern that consists of nothing more than a sine wave going from the middle out.
Now a sine wave just goes up and down, up and down, up and down all the way out to the end of the photographic plate.
So if you have a diagramic molecule, all the rings in their intensity would look like a sine wave.
Just from the beginning, up, down, up, down, up, down, the spacing would be identical between them aside from some geometric factors that I don't have to go into.
All you have to do is to measure the frequency, oh, I should say that the farther apart the two atoms are that are giving rise to this sine wave, the greater the frequency of the sine wave.
The two atoms that are far apart like this give a sine wave that goes up and down very rapidly, two atoms that are very close together will give a sine wave that has a very long wavelength.
So you'll see very few rings.
So all you'd have to do is to measure the spacing between these rings and that is related by theory to how far apart the atoms are.
Well that's for a diatomic, let's say that's the case for a diatomic molecule. You only have one sine wave.
The diatomic molecule vibrates and so the atoms are not rigid, they're moving back and forth away from one another like two balls on a spring.
And of course that means that the distance isn't constant. Well it turns out according to theory to a good approximation, this sine wave instead of having constant amplitude all the way up dies off due to this vibration.
So you measure the dying off of the sine wave and that tells you how big the amplitude of this vibration is.
So we learn about two things, the distances between the atoms on the average and we learn about how much they're moving with respect to one another by measuring the damping off of the sine wave.
Well of course there aren't many diatomic molecules left to study but every that problem or rather the theory that I mentioned applies to just the pairs of atoms.
So if you have a molecule that has more than just two atoms in it you're going to have more than two distances, more than one distance.
Every pair of atoms in the molecule gives rise to one of these sine waves. So carbon dioxide as a linear molecule is a carbon oxygen bond and that gives rise to a single sine wave that goes out.
There are two of them but they have exactly the same distance so there are two sine waves that are right on top of one another.
Then you have the distance between the oxygen atoms and that's twice as big. So it generates a sine wave also which has a frequency twice as great to first approximation as the frequency of the carbon oxygen because the distance is twice as long.
And that gives a sine wave that oscillates with twice the frequency and the first one and they're on top of one another.
So the pattern is no longer a simple sine wave but a collection of two sine waves. If you know how to separate out these sine waves and measure their frequencies then you know exactly what the structure of this molecule is.
So CO2 were bent like NO2 is, NO2 would be entirely similar but there you would find the distances between the oxygen atoms, the distance between the oxygen atoms is not twice the distance between the nitrogen and oxygen because it's a triangular molecule like this.
So oxygen-oxygen distance would not be moving twice the frequency of the NO but less than that.
So you can immediately determine that distance and determine the nitrogen-oxygen distance and by comparing them you know what the bond angle is in the molecule.
This simple account can be applied to molecules that are very, very complicated. The entire problem man is just to separate out what these different sine waves are, construct yourself a model that will account for all of the distances and then you have the structure of the molecule.
It is in practice considerably more complicated than I'm telling you but that's essentially the features of the whole thing.
Now you ask how we do this. Well we have to measure the frequencies and to do that we have a scanner, what is called a microdensitometer.
The film is placed on the bed of this microdensitometer and the film in the apparatus that I have, we have a mechanism that rotates the film around its center.
The purpose of this is that you are averaging the information around the entire circle that is if the densitometer consists of a beam that passes through the film and a detector that measures how intense the light beam is as it comes through the film.
So when the ring is intense the light beam that comes through is much reduced and when the film is very more transparent the beam that comes through there is more intense.
So you get a recording of the blackness of the film. So this thing translates and we have electronic data accumulation system that measures the intensity of the blackness of the film as a function from the center outward.
And that gives us digital data and that's what we actually work with to analyze. So that's essentially it and without having you in the laboratory for a week I can't tell you much more that when I get clear here I don't think.
So any other questions about that?
This largely comes from your own interest or in my case my own interest let's say or the principal investigator's interest.
Now if we take C60 for example that was big news at the time it was discovered and I had a former student named Bob Johnson who was working at IBM.
In San Jose and they had managed to create or had a sample of this stuff. Now in the beginning it was very rare.
I mean a few well you could get it in in milligram quantities.
And I the sample that I actually worked with I think had 300 milligrams in it and it was a little bit of black powder in a vial.
And at going market prices that was $5,000 worth of sample. Well Bob wrote to me and he asked me how could we do this could you do this work.
I don't know what very exciting we should try. And so they supplied the sample. Several people in IBM and were involved in this project and leasing me up here.
And so we got the sample and we managed to it was very exciting because I didn't know whether we were going to be able to get a pattern from this stuff at all because it was so refractory.
You know we had to heat it so hot and the oven that we had it was so hot it was going red in the apparatus.
Now fortunately the film that we use is not very sensitive to red light. Secondly I was able to build a shield around the novel that protected the film from almost all of the glow.
As I heated it up I could see it glowing bright red in there and then I would close up the window to the apparatus and turn off the beam, lecture on beam and quickly move the plate in position.
Open up the beam and expose this. I could not see evidence of any we have a fluorescent screen in there that we can see patterns on for most molecules.
At the time we did the experiment I couldn't see anything on this fluorescent screen other than a very faint glow from the screen so I didn't know whether we were getting anything or not.
And so we made two or three of these exposures and I took the film into the dark room and I couldn't believe my eyes when I saw how beautiful a pattern was.
You couldn't have predicted it would be like that or that you would even get one from seeing there was no evidence. Normally when I run stuff on the apparatus I put the main beam through a slot on a fluorescent screen so I can see the scattering all around it.
And I can see it you know just it'll look like this on a black thing somewhat reduced. I can see we're getting scattering couldn't see that with C60 and yet there it was and absolutely beautiful pattern.
It was very exciting.
Was it what? Well it turns out Bucky balls if you pick up a soccer ball and you look to see how the things are put together there are hexagons in it and pentagons in it.
And they are put together in a completely symmetric way and it turns out that in Bucky balls or on a soccer thing the length of the stitching in a soccer ball.
It's a little hard to describe but there are bonds that link two six member patches together and stitches that link a six member to a five member and those two bond links are different in C60 itself.
Those are the only two parameters that are necessary to determine the structure of C60 assuming that it is a soccer ball. That's the assumption that you make and that was well characterized by NMR spectra and other things.
So we knew it was a soccer ball type but we didn't know what the length of these bonds were.
So if you then have the only thing that changes it doesn't change the shape it only changes the size of the six member and the five member ring as you change the length of these bonds.
Well, we had to put together a model that is to say that would you see what you actually do in analysis you have the experimental pattern and then you have to generate a model
and compare the pattern that this model gives with the one that you experience experimentally.
So you are fitting a model for which you have calculated a pattern.
And you adjust that pattern to fit the experiment by changing the parameters of the model.
So to make this applying this to C60 the pattern depends only on the relative lengths of those two distances that I mentioned.
The one between six member rings and the one between a six and a five member ring.
And so my wife then put together the model and you can imagine it's not easy.
You have to remember generate every distance in the molecule from just these two parameters.
There are 720 distances in the molecule and she constructed a program that would calculate this model for us.
And that was the one we used and tested and that led finally to the fitting and the structure of the thing.
And we published that in science a couple of decades ago now I guess.
Very little lots of fun.
I wanted to ask also about xenon hexafloid.
Which one?
Oh, xenon hexafloid.
We never actually finished the structure of that thing because a friend of mine at the University of Michigan had done a very good job
and he was in the head of us.
We worked on other xenon compounds.
We did xenon tetroxide which is four oxygen atoms arranged in the form of a tetrahedron around a xenon atom.
And that was quite an experience because a very explosive compound.
We had several minor explosions with it.
We had to generate the compound on the apparatus by adding acid to a perzenate as it's called.
A compound which contains xenon but it's a salt.
And we had to build an apparatus where we could tip this up slightly and add acid to this where upon the xenon tetroxide would be formed and could flow into our apparatus through our nozzle.
But we several times the stuff in the gas phase is very unstable.
We had several times very minor explosions and minor in the sense that there was no danger to anybody involved here but it blew holes in our conducting line right away.
So we had that happen several times.
That's the only xenon compound that we actually finished the structure on xenon tetroxide.
Were there other compounds there particularly memorable or rewind?
Well, the ones that we've talked about are one sort of in the public eye.
I think in terms of public interest of something very novel probably not so much.
The work that we do I've always tended to characterize in the term used in the old days which is basic research.
I had no really discernible practical applications but it was fundamental stuff and there are a lot of fundamental problems in chemistry.
For example, chemistry as it is practiced at some level or another makes continuous and intimate use of the concept of the structure of the things you're dealing with.
I mean we talk about the structural proteins for example.
We talk about the structure of almost everything in organic chemistry all structures when he lectures on the board.
So we were involved in determining structures but what we were doing is actually measuring these structures to very high precision.
We're not just making a ball and stick drawing.
We're looking at the distances between the atoms and trying to deduce from this.
How these distances might be related to the reactivity of the molecule and things of that sort.
Now how the intimate details of the structure, distances, well let's me put it this way, size and shape of the molecule are related to its reactivity.
I can give you one example of this that most people don't know about but a very common chemical compound in nature is nitrogen dioxide that comes from combustion of internal engines under high temperatures and so on.
Nitrogen dioxide is a triangular molecule with a nitrogen at the apex and two of these nitrogen oxides, nitrogen dioxide molecules come together and they form a dimer that has, it's called dionitrogen tetraxide then.
Now a remarkable thing of this is that these two molecules come together and fall apart, come together and fall apart just so easily.
If you have N02 and the gas phase, you have N204 and the gas phase also as you change the temperature and pressure the amount of one of these with respect to the other changes.
Well N204 is very hard to, it falls apart so easily, it's very hard to measure, the structure on it but we undertook that job.
The way it was done is that we got a sample of N02 and the reaction for the decomposition or our dimerization or dimerization is extremely rapid, it just flows apart immediately or comes together immediately.
We cool it down, the stream down, what happens is you get more and more of N204 as you heat it up, all of this is decomposed right away because of the thermal effects.
So what we did was cool the oven, sorry the nozzle way, way down, well way down below zero Celsius, run the stuff through it and we got beautiful pictures of N204.
Then we heated it up a little bit and we could see all the characteristic distances for that molecule beginning to disappear as if the higher we heated it, the less of those we had, we got it to 100 in some odd degrees, there's nothing but N02 present.
Well the structure of N204 turned out to be very interesting, it turns out that there is an extraordinarily long N bond.
The bonds between atoms in typical compounds tend to be more or less the same, for example saturated hydrocarbons have carbon carbon bonds and I can tell you right away they will be 1.54 or 1.535 angstroms to within 100th of an angstrom and no matter what compound you look at.
Well there's a characteristic N N bond, two N N O bonds and it turned out that this N N bond was very, very long.
So much so that by a simple criterion that Linus Pauling had produced one time, it's only the order of a tenth as strong as a normal single bond.
So that accounts for what follows the power very easily. But one thing that's characteristic of single bonds is that the two N's on the molecule can rotate around like this you see, they're not fixed like this because the bond is a weak to our intense surprise that's not the case of N204.
It's a flat planar molecule no matter how long this bond is.
So what is it that holds the flat you see? Well that's not a single bond, don't hold things flat. Why is this flat? Well that was the interesting question of the time.
And it turns out that the structure of the N O2 part of the N204 molecule is almost identically that of the separated N O2.
That is bringing the two together to make the dime or doesn't change the structure of the ends at all.
Normally if you bring them together, if you take two monomers and you bring them together, these will change somewhat in angles and distances, not within the N204.
But these are puzzles that are just lots of fun to think about, that's all.
And so this kind of research is the thing that's characterized what Lisa and I have done most of our career here.
We have all sorts of different systems that pose different basic chemical questions.
And we look at molecules to try to find out what we can learn about these basic chemical questions, answers to them from studying the structures of maybe even a series of several molecules that have other, some things in common, some things different to see how the differences and so on affect the properties of the molecules.
So that's what we do.
So you got your apparatus constructed, do I presume that your piece of wood decreased some?
Well, in due course, and those days the chemistry department consisted of four divisions.
There was organic, inorganic, physical, and analytical. They were pretty clearly defined.
People were in these divisions in accordance with the kind of research they did.
Well, they came in opening in physical chemistry.
And Gilbert as chairman told me immediately that when that opening occurred, he was going to move me into that division.
Well, this was two or three years later. The other, oh, but the two jobs were filled that this monitoring of the laboratories that brought me here.
Caldwell's efforts.
The other person was Tom Parsons. Tom Parsons was in chemistry for a while, but moved into administration and finished his career here as an administrator.
Well, that I moved into physical chemistry, Gilbert, and I became a physical chemist of my teaching responsibility has changed a lot.
I no longer rode herd on the TAs, but I still taught general chemistry, but I also began to teach courses regularly in physical chemistry.
So, my contact hours went down, but the amount of time I spent working certainly didn't because now I had the contact hours before.
I knew the experiments and freshmen chemistry the kids were doing, and I could walk through and make sure that they were getting a proper attention and so on.
But now I had to prepare lectures and in courses that I hadn't lectured in before.
But the contact hours went down, but the amount of time spent teaching didn't diminish for quite a while.
But nevertheless, my apparatus was coming along, and I was very lucky when I came here because I had all the money I needed to build this.
I got some money from the research corporation before I arrived. I applied for that at Celtic, and I came with a Sloan Foundation grant, which was five years of money that I used for summer support, and I wasn't teaching, and then I could do fully to
drawing up parts from apparatus and so on. And then I got NSF support too, so I've never lacked for funding.
The main thing that I've had trouble with is the time in the early days, not in the later days.
So things have turned out later days that teaching loads gradually began to fall into a, oh, I don't want to put it, a race that was consistent with what we're being taught at other institutions with which we competed the time.
So there was still a lot of teaching, but it was a kind that there was really lots of fun.
What was the environment like in the department back then?
Oh, it was very collegial. Collegial was at the word. We were all very friendly with one another.
I mean, socially, I had friends in physical chemistry and organic chemistry, and we saw one another at analytical chemistry at dinner parties, we did lots of things together.
New Year's Eve parties and so on. So it was, in my opinion, a lot more cohesive than it is at the moment.
And at the time, a lot more cohesive at Oregon State than in many institutions. In many institutions, there is a kind of a very wary attitude or outlook
from one divisional type to another, and sometimes even within the members of the division,
you have to realize that university teaching, university careers can be very competitive, especially those that depend a good deal on research that you do as well as on your teaching.
And so you read about this all the time of the press of people that are competing for even publicly sometimes for priority and some major discovery.
But we never had any of that in chemistry. We just had a very good time. That's been a fine place.
At what point did Lisa start working at OSU?
I'm sorry?
Oh, that was a history that was very interesting.
Lisa decided, did I mention how we met? Yeah, well, when we came to the stage, she was a scientist, and we worked together at Caltech.
She was actually paid at Caltech, and we worked in electron diffraction. They are both of us together in the same project.
Did several things happen?
Then when we came to Oregon, she was very busy, of course, with our son, who was only three months old when we arrived.
So she didn't work at all at that point, except, well, that's not quite true, because we did manage to find some babysitting for a few hours a day now and then when she could come to the university.
But she was never away from home, more than two or three hours at a time then.
And that, a couple of years later, our daughter was born, so then we had two kids at home.
And so by and large, she worked only sporadically until the kids got into nursery school when she could then drive them up.
They were on orchard street here in the university nursery school, which has changed its location, I think, somewhat.
But the kids would go there, and she would come to the laboratory, and then when their sessions over, she'd take them up to go home.
And we live very close to the Jefferson School, so until both of them got into school, she was home most of the time.
But managed to put in several hours per week, working on our projects at that time.
Then when the kids went to Jefferson School, she could in the morning, and the kids would get to rest, I'd go off to work.
The kids would get to our school and start, they would run out the front door, go over to the school, and we'd let the teachers know what phone to call.
Then Lisa would get into her car and drive over to the university and we would work until about two or three years so, when she would get in the car and go home, park the car and get in the house.
The kids would run out of the school and come back. They never knew she actually worked, because of course they were concerned she was there when they left and there when it came home.
But she was able to work about half time then. She was paid by a line on them, a line on them in the budget for grants, as I had succeeded in getting.
And then we also had joint grants. And then she's very good at mathematics and she was hired by the computer center to be working on, she was very good at programming and so on.
And she was kind of a liaison with chemistry and programming in the computer center. That was when we still had centralized computing.
Then we had one rhubarb. I might have told you this, but I haven't before, but it went something like this.
Gilbert had retired and Bert Christensen had become chairman.
And Lisa had been working on my grant for the line item and the budget for her salary.
And the proposal that had been department chairman had to sign the proposal and Bert did that. And so it was funded.
And then he decided one time that she could no longer work on the grant after her, after the present year was over academic year.
And so she wrote him a letter and pointed out that she had item for a salary, was never explained what the reason was.
And he responded and she wrote again and he didn't respond.
It turned out in retrospect that he was greatly afraid that there would be some negative feeling about a man and wife working together
in the chemistry department, because at that time there was no one heard of, but it was a little unusual.
The thing was, she was not being paid on state funds at all. And she was an expert in the field in which there were no other west of the Mississippi.
Well, he persisted in this, so we finally went over to together to the dean who was Vern Scholoam at that time.
And said, I knew him very well from years. I said, Vern, look, this is a situation.
He said, well, why didn't you tell me this before? I said, well, this Lisa said this too. Well, we were going through channels. Our issue was not with you with with Christensen.
So he looked at this and he says, well, he says she can certainly work on the grant.
The proposal by the way had been signed by Bert and now he was refusing to continue on funding, even though he has signed the agreement.
So he overturned this. But then he said, if Lisa wants to work in the future, she'll have to have her name on the grant, not just worked on your grant.
Well, I can't remember much of the details following that, but it turned out that Christensen was about to retire.
There are circumstances here that I don't need to go into. But anyway, he was going to retire and a new one man was going to come.
And I was on a national committee at the time and I was a former friend of mine at Caltech, named Dave Schumacher, was on the same committee.
Dave and I mentioned to him. He was from Idaho, of course, and gone to Reed College and we'd gone to Caltech together.
He finished a little earlier than I did. I said, Dave, would you, we need a new department chairman.
He was chairman of the committee. I was on. I saw how good he was at a ministering thing.
Would you, by any criteria, even consider coming back, maybe being considered as our department chairman.
There was a lot of talk about this that he decided that, yes, he might like that. He was at MIT at the time. So we invited him out.
And he was off of the job and he liked Oregon. You know, it was very, very similar to a group and went to school employment.
But one of the criteria for him coming was that his wife would be able to work.
Here was another man on the wife team. She was a crystallographer as he was.
And McVicar was the chairman of this time. And one of the conditions for him coming was that his wife be allowed to work.
And then he said, oh, by the way, he says, you know, Ken and Lisa have the same problem.
And so, of McVicar came around today, he says, that's no problem. He says, I've looked this all up.
He says, two members of the same family cannot work, not only in the same department or same institution, but in the same entire system of higher education, except under unusual circumstances.
And he said, this is McVicar's words. Dave relayed them to me. He said, I regard a man and wife's scientific team as an unusual circumstance.
So Dave came. His wife was allowed to work with him. And at the same time, Lisa was allowed to work with me.
The really remarkable and most interesting thing about this, there was one small attempt to cover the tracks here.
And that was that Clara Schumacher was responsible to me. And Lisa was responsible to Dave for monitoring purposes.
But of course, Dave came around and he said, well, he said, how's Lisa doing fine?
I said, then he says, how's Clara doing? I said, oh, fine. So, that was that. That was the monitoring.
And of course, that all disappeared in the end. But in retrospect, it's pretty funny. So that's how we were able to continue.
So Lisa did a lot of computer work.
Pardon?
Lisa did a lot of computer work?
Well, yeah. But not just computer work. She's a special expert in programming.
That has evolved during the ages that we've been here. But she is responsible for all the basic materials that we use in our research even today.
Some of these programs have been modified by others and even added to by others.
But the basic thing, she is responsible for.
That's very funny.
Can you reflect on the early days of your computers and your work?
Computers and work?
Yeah, well, yes. When I left Caltech, we had some IBM office machines. And we were able to operate them using IBM punched cards.
We had a very, for the time, very efficient system for doing the calculations and necessary for our work and electron diffraction.
When I came to Oregon State, we didn't have this IBM setup here at all.
But the mathematics department had managed to, the applied aspect of mathematics here was very interested in computers.
And the central computer by IBM had been developed a few years earlier.
And there was a computer that they managed to buy in mathematics. It was called an All-Act 3E.
They sold a few of these things. And we had one here. It was set up and running in mathematics and the basement.
It was a tube machine. I mean, it was a huge thing with tapes and vacuum tubes.
Transistors hadn't been invented yet. At least were not available and a device like this.
And so we wrote together. I did programming when I first came here. There was no compiler for this machine. So we had to write things in machine language.
And I learned enough to do that and wrote the very earliest programs in machine language that were run on the All-Act 3E.
Well, the All-Act 3E, as our analytical scheme improved, the programs got more and more lengthy as far as that machine was concerned.
And the machine by this time was beginning to teeter a bit.
And there were some graduate students over there on mathematics that managed to know what tubes to interchange and exchange for the keep this thing running.
But we had to write our early programs in such a way we couldn't rely on the machine because it would make errors due to faulty hardware.
And so we wrote our programs in such a way that we could run them twice and if we got the same answer, we could continue to the next stage.
And Lisa and I wrote those programs. Then, by the way, I had some money and to use the machine, you had to pay.
So I, at one stage, gave them a few hundred dollars from one of my grants against future computing so they could buy vacuum tubes to put into this machine.
Believe it or not.
Harvard Lonseth was the chairman of mathematics at that time. Very nice guy.
So, a couple of years later, it turned out that statistics had gotten hold of an IBM machine.
It was running on punch cards but it had a compiler and so on. And so we moved to that. That was a central computer. They charged also.
But it was a much better machine than the 1410, I think it was called.
And then things progressed around here. We were still doing central computing. There was a central computing center that was set up and they bought a CDC machine.
And that CDC machine was better still, faster. And by this time, we had altered our programming so that we could access the machine remotely through a telephone line.
And we had a teletype terminal in the laboratory. So on data from our experiments could be put out on punched paper tape.
And that punched paper tape could be fed into our terminal and carried over to the computer. We thought this was boy, we were really ahead of things there. It was great.
Then it turned out that was heavy demand for that machine. And the amount of storage we needed for some of our programs was huge. And they didn't have enough of it, see?
So we were limited into how much storage we could use in any of our programs.
So Lisa very, very cleverly took our biggest, most demanding programs and created it to operate with overlays and so on.
That instead of saving something, she determined what would be needed and wrote the program. So succeeding stages could write right over this stuff.
And so this occurred. And in that way, the program became very efficient as far as space was concerned. And then we still needed space. So I talked to them over there and they said, oh, well, you can have more space after the hours of such and such.
So we would set up stuff to run on this machine at a later time.
Then of course, that was the time that Lisa, one of the times when Lisa was hired to be working over there. Then the central computing, of course, began to gradually disappear as PCs came in.
And right away, well, before that happened in chemistry, we determined that we needed a computer locally. And we managed to get a grant. Several of us pooled our knowledge and resources and made a proposal.
And we were able to buy a Vax. And Lisa then converted all our programs to run on the Vax. And that was tremendous.
And we have lots of programs, including plotting ones. We had a plotter also. That would work just fine.
And then of course, the Vax began to be phased out. And we had a PDP 11 in our laboratory, finally, leads in me.
And so some of our stuff was ran on that. But this is all very closely stuff. And the PDP 11 used large disks like this, floppy disks that were 8 inches or 10 inches in diameter.
Then PCs began to appear on the scene. And so, at one stage or another, I could see that there was going to be no expertise around at all or do anything about PDP 11's.
Everything was going to be going to PCs. So if we wanted to keep current and not be high and dry, that if something happened to the PD 11, nobody would know what to do.
So we converted all of our stuff to run on PCs. And all of our data all through the years had been stored on these disks on the PDP 11.
Well, we hired a guy to convert all of the stuff on the PD 11 onto disks that could in a format that can be used on smaller, well smaller, but faster PCs.
And these were all on floppy disks like this. Well, pretty soon those disappeared. And we had to convert them to some other medium. And so we took all of this stuff and copied them all over on the CDs that are now like this. And I have a host of things on CDs.
But also a whole pile of stuff on these floppies, all catalogued. And I've maintained on a couple of the PCs in my laboratory, a floppy disk drive that will still accept these old ones.
There's no reason to change it to anything else. But now we've gone to extremely fast computers. A calculation on the all WAC 3E would take us two days we can now do in about 10 seconds, something like that.
They're so fast now. And the storage is so enormous enough. I can get a program going in a hit return. I can't get my hands on my lap before all the information is on the screen again. It's been a total revolution.
Well, in the midst of all this, some place back we had a special tectronics scope, which could feed data inward plump things for us. We can see it on the screen there. And my son later went on to a electric engineering degree and Stanford. And as a software engineer at Microsoft, now when he was in high school, he loved these computers.
And he could program also. And so he played it, believe it or not, a big role in some of the very early developing, because when he was at Stanford, he would come home and say, well, what do you need now, Dad? Still interested in that.
I should say one other thing. Our kids were kind of interested in science. And so Eric and Lisa and I published a paper together on work that he had actually worked on the laboratory. And this is a paper by Hadbrook, Hadbrook and Hadbrook.
And it was published in the Journal of Chemical Physics. And a few years later, my daughter was interested. We published a paper, another one by Hadbrook, Hadbrook and Hadbrook. And I never managed to get the two kids to the laboratory at the same time so we could have four Hadbrooks on it.
One time I called up the Journal Editor of Chemical Physics, a man named Willard Stout, way back when I said, this is Ken Hadbrook. And he said, oh, of Hadbrook, Hadbrook and Hadbrook. Apparently he had noticed this. So anyway, that's more or less the story of computing.
Okay, well, the last question for today, when we were at your office, we've seen the final folders. And can you explain what the final folders are and still we have that in record?
But the final folders are. There are several stages in the analysis of a structure. And they begin with the raw data that we get from using this microdensity
data, which is the data that we get from the raw data. And these raw data are the first things that go into the folder.
Now, a lot of things have to be done to that raw data because after all, you're taking what is a continuous curve and you're sampling it at very small intervals along it.
And we have points that correspond to this. Now, when the plate or film moves across the dense automator, it goes across the middle and back out on the other side.
So we scan the film from one side to the other. But all the time it's rotating, which means that half of the film should be identical to the other.
And half of the trace should be identical to the other half. But since you're sampling by points, you can't make sure that these points are identical.
So you have to do something as we call, find the center. So we have a program that compares the two sides of this and determines where the center is.
And then it takes the data on one side and that on the other, interpolates if necessary between the points, adds them all together to give you a scan.
That's all in there, finding the center. So we have the curve and counts. We have the curve curves that find the center.
And then we have the data, which are just numbers. We want to convert them to something which has a common basis.
And because of the properties of the dense automator, a very black film can give you the same range of numbers that a very light film can.
But there's obviously a lot more scattering and one than in the other. So we have a way of converting this information to let us call it absolute densities.
It's not really that, but it really puts the two curves on the same scale in terms of darkness and so on.
Then we have a number of programs that are designed to convert this. There is a difference between the blackness of the film and the intensity of the scattering.
Now, you can get a sense of this where, for example, if you take a film and expose it for a second, you get a certain darkness.
Suppose that for two seconds, you get another darkness. And of course, if in the right range, the blackness of the second would be, if you expose twice as long under identical condition, the blackness would be twice as great.
Well, clearly, the longer you expose, the less the photographic film is going to respond. So pretty soon it gets black and it doesn't matter how long you expose, not going to get any blacker.
So the curve that relates blackness to intensity is not linear. We have to find out how non-linear it is in terms of how dark the film is.
So we have corrections for that. We have a whole host of corrections that are built into this that is designed to take the data from the film and put it into a form which compares with mathematically with a theoretical function that we can calculate.
And there are many steps in this process. Each one of these steps builds up to this point.
And then, when we've got all of that, we then have, we do a number of calculations.
The most important of which is the final fitting procedure. And it's called a least squares adjustment. And so this is a program that fits the final model to the experimental data.
And the result of that is an output in the folder that shows the fitting quality of this.
And then there are often plots of the curves at various stages of this procedure. So it all goes into the line printer output which those days we call the final folder.
It might be anywhere from two inches thick, well anywhere from an inch thick to three inches thick, say.
And that's what you saw in those line printer folders. Now we have almost the same thing nowadays. But it is all done.
Eight and a half by 11 stuff, you see.
When we're doing a hard copy that we want to look at. But now we actually put all this stuff on a disk on a CD.
And it's all, we have folders on the computer for molecules that contain all the information we want. And then some folders and some folders.
And I take these, the major folder and I'll just copy the whole thing over onto a CD.
And I'll give it a name for the molecule and everything we want. Now we can put on this CD. Look in there. We can find it right away.
So it's a hard copy stuff that you saw in the laboratory. Really is stuff that we stopped generating maybe 20 years ago.
And the later stuff is all in either in folders or on hard copy or on devices like CDs.
I read recently, somebody was saying CDs are going to disappear also. So maybe it'll all be on a thumb drive now, who knows.
Okay, well, we've been gone for an hour and a half. All right. Good. All right.